it was certainly understandable why so
many dexter fans were skeptical of
dexter new blood when showtime first
announced plans for the series the last
episode of dexter is one of the most
universally despised series finales in
the history of television
however over the course of its first
season dexter new blood would seem to
have proven itself a valued continuation
of the original series the penultimate
episode of the reboot's first season
episode 9 the family business currently
sits at a 9.7 out of 10 rating on imdb
certainly a far cry from the original
series finale of dexter which is
currently only managing 4.6 stars on the
same site as reviews and reactions for
the finale of dexter new blood continue
to flood in it will be interesting to
see if fans of the series prefer this as
a more definitive ending or want to see
it as a first part of a new entry of the
franchise here's a quick explainer about
where the last episode leaves things
originally introduced as a kind-hearted
owner of a local business curt caldwell
played by clancy brown is slowly
revealed to be a monster who murders
helpless women even though michael c
hall's dexter morgan kills and
dismembers kurt in episode 9 the late
serial killer's presence still looms
large over the events of the season
finale before he winds up sealed in
plastic kurt sets fire to dexter's cabin
and mails iron lake police chief angela
bishop a letter that proves dexter
killed matt caldwell kurt's final
actions are very reminiscent of those of
arthur mitchell aka trinity played by
john lithgow in the season 4 finale of
the original dexter series in that
episode dexter murders trinity and
returns home only to discover that
trinity has already murdered his wife
rita and left his son harrison crying in
a pool of blood despite technically
winning the battle few would contest
that dexter ultimately lost the war with
trinity similarly ker's letter to angela
and his subsequent burning of dexter's
cabin directly lead to dexter's arrest
in the finale if she stands over the
smouldering remnants of dexter's cabin
angela locates a titanium screw that
previously held matt's leg together with
all the proof she needs angela arrests
dexter for murder and makes a quick call
to one angel batista of the miami metro
police department once again a dexter's
enemy bests him from the beyond
after decades of murder and
dismemberment dexter finally meets his
own end in the last moments of dexter
new blood the final episode sees the
famous serial killer cornered at all
angles by his former girlfriend who
promises to extradite the infamous bay
harbour butcher to florida where he
would surely face the death penalty
unwilling to accept his fate dexter
makes a mad dash escape from the jail
leaving a bloody trail in the process
dexter rushes to harrison but the elder
morgan's killing of sergeant logan is a
step too far for the young serial killer
in training who recognizes that dexter's
actions violate the code that is sun's
urging dexter considers the plethora of
innocent people who have died as a
result of his actions we see flashes of
logan laguerta dokes lundy harry riza
and deborah all people who suffered
untimely deaths because of their
proximity to dexter faced with the truth
of his past dexter admits to harrison is
right and invites his son to shoot him
in the chest while not exactly the same
as showrunner clyde philip's original
plan for the dexter series finale the
highlighting of dexter's truly innocent
victims represents a similar narrative
choice in that he is finally forced to
take responsibility for his actions just
prior to his own death throughout dexter
and dexter new blood dexter makes it
clear that he is unable to feel genuine
emotion despite how normal he may seem
to some people in season episode 1 he
says people fake a lot of human
interactions
but i feel like i faked them all and i
faked them very well by the end of the
series dexter admits that his emotional
mimicry and violent urges will always
hurt those close to him he abandons
harrison to spare him the suffering in
furtherance of this goal dexter also
initially refuses to have anything to do
with harrison when he arrives in iron
lake however despite pleas from
deborah's post-mortem manifestation
dexter eventually embraces harrison as a
son teaching him the code and even
inviting him into his kill room sadly
deborah's pleased with seems to have
been well-founded the code is ultimately
proven unable to prevent dexter from
harming numerous innocent people
realizing that dexter is the person
responsible for most of the suffering in
his life harrison openly blames his
father for his mother's murder his
aunt's death and his own dark tendencies
harrison screams
open your eyes and look at what you've
done slowly dexter comes to grips with
the truth in harrison's words telling
his son that he deserves a better life
and a better father just before harrison
shoots his father dexter notes i've
never really felt love
[Music]
real love
until now it has certainly taken some
time for him to learn but dexter's final
moments seem to offer him some
understanding of what it means to
actually be human it's difficult to tell
where things could go after this type of
a finale with the titular character dead
the future seems somewhat limited of
course any speculation about any more
potential seasons of dexter new blood
it's bound to focus on harrison who
leaves iron lake with no specific
destination in mind as he departs iron
lake harrison reads an old letter
written by dexter to hannah mckay in
which his father affectionately refers
to harrison as his quote phantom limb
and says that a normal life will never
be possible for him so long as he is
around
while one interpretation of this scene
is that harrison can live a normal life
now that his father is dead a darker
interpretation is also equally likely
harrison has previously displayed a
multitude of dark tendencies much like
his father it's unclear if harrison will
be able to hold his dark passenger at
bay without his father's assistance
however normal harrison manages to make
his future that voice which guides him
could at some point take on the form of
a familiar face in the original series
dexter's dark passenger is represented
by his deceased father and mentor harry
morgan given dexter's role in his son's
life it's possible that harrison's
memory of his father could one day
occupy the same function that voice in
the finale might just be the beginning
of dexter's own post-modern
manifestation inside harrison's head
while a show called harrison probably
wouldn't have quite the same appeal as
dexter perhaps someone out there is
already trademarking something like
dexter afterlife with this very plan in
mind
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you